vous faites ça depuis combien de temps
40 ans
apparemment quelqu'un a tenté de
s'échapper en griffant
il y a eu une gamine dans cette cage
nous recherchons une jeune fille ça vous
met toujours en rogne
j'ai un temps superbe c'est chouette de
savoir que vous êtes là les filles
j'ai pas été aussi heureux de te voir
depuis que tu es arrivé avec maman
t'avais dit que c'était fini ça c'est la
dernière livraison je te promets il est
où le paquet
vous comprenez pas je prends pas de gens
dans mon camion je peux pas te promettre
qu'il arrivera rien à ton frère si tu
conduis pas la gamine à sa destination
vous n'êtes pas en train de suggérer
qu'on passe en revue tous les relais
routiers de la région
c'est ça le terrain
on est deux dans ce bateau
il y a des personnes mal intentionnées
qui veulent du mal à se gamine
et il nous laisseront tranquille je veux
pas qu'elle retourne là-bas
[Musique]
et toi
tout ce que je veux c'est l'aider et de
ceux qui lui veulent du bien
j'ai rejoint le FBI pour me sentir
important
[Musique]
et de la chance au moins tu as une
destination moi je sais seulement où je
veux pas aller
[Musique]
la dernière chose dont on a besoin ce
qu'une bande de flics se met à leur
courir après
[Musique]
elle a besoin de nous
tout comme on a besoin l'un de l'autre
et vous alors ça n'a pas d'importance
pourquoi ce qui compte c'est ce que je
fais